hi Kristen how are you today are you
better than I deserve what's up in your
world well I was recently accepted to
nurse practitioner school good for you
currently thank you I'm currently a
nurse working at a high school making
pretty good money for that but we are
about to send two children to college so
by the time I get out of school the kids
will be going and I was just wondering
if you had any tips on how to finance my
part of the education so we can send
them through without coming out with
that yeah
can you not cash flow it we probably can
- I'm a real bad with that you're real
bad with that I'm real bad with
budgeting and paying attention to that
my husband and I go back and forth about
we got every dollar and he's just way
better about keeping up with it but he
doesn't spend the money so I'm nervous
because I don't see where it's going to
come from okay so what is your household
income now we make just a little more
than two hundred thousand dollars a year
okay and where does all that go well we
we don't have much debt so it just goes
so um kind of sounds obviously make it
$200,000 a year double pay for nursing
school right my concern also is timing
with we've got one about to start
driving we're going to have to get a
third car add her to insurance and our
in our expenditures are going to go up
with that as well so so she gets a
$2,000 car exactly
God wish you could tell her now I just
did she gets to go to school without
that because we're motoring willing to
go back to school to get her nursing
through her grad work in nursing right
and so that the family can cash flow for
her to go to school all right
she doesn't get to pick unless she has
the money that night unless she has a
minor right to check in which case she
gets
say in what she picks no and that's not
the case oh so she doesn't get the pen
so when you say cashflow school I mean
will they take a monthly payment or how
does that work well you make $10,000 a
year you save up the first year the
first year's tuition before you go right
it's not that expensive right all right
what 30 40 grand we'll put you through
is a two-year program it correct yeah so
you need 60 grand out of 200 right well
I still leave you 140 you can't live on
behind 40 in Charlotte North Carolina
oh I can yeah the second year I won't
work so here's what I'm talking about
the the point is that what you are
better at budgeting then you admit and
let me show you what I'm talking about
let's say you needed sixty thousand
dollars to save the life of one of your
children you would be a budgeting
freaking expert wouldn't you yeah yeah
so we can do what we want to do that's
right and so do you want this badly
enough that's the question to actually
roll up your sleeves and go hey we're
all bearing down here people you get a
$2,000 car shut up there's no vacation
we're not going out to eat all the time
we're going to live on a written budget
Mama's going back to school why so you
people can all go to school debt-free
because I'm working my butt off and
you're going to remember the day that
your mama paid a price for you people to
win okay and we're all leaning into this
is a family for the next two years right
and then you dive in the school and you
finish it and you because the great news
is you guys make great money right I was
scared to death when I was talking to
you're going to tell me you made $30,000
years no I'm worried I don't know if I'm
gonna do this but I'll pick on you a
little bit you dumb people don't get to
go to graduate school okay okay so
you're smart enough to do this you're
just being lazy that's right that's
right absolutely true I'll give it to
you
[Laughter]
well I think I think you're awesome
people and I think you're going to do a
great job and but it's just you know
treat every daughter like your life
depends on it treat Financial Peace
University like your life depends on it
and all of a sudden you get really good
at it
and here's the thing it's just a
decision I mean you remember when you
took your boards yeah what you do
completely leaned in and focused to the
exclusion of all other goals right and
that's how you passed because you don't
pass those things being lazy you don't
pass those things sliding into home
right you got to step on it right mm-hmm
that's all I'm telling you to do you
know how to use y'all we're doing is
just changing the subject it's not
nursing its money but the good life is
it's not rocket science you don't have
to have a freakin master's degree to
figure this out it's sixth grade math
it's making you behave your husband
behave your kids mave so that we hit a
higher more noble goal which is
education for you which then provides
extra income to provide education for
the rest of kids this is a great goal
there's a real reason you got a really
nice big why here and if you got a big
why you can sacrifice to win right you
got this you call me if I can help okay
thanks they might say thank you hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]